hello everyone
uh hello youtube welcome to our live q a
with bradstone
i'm susie jackson i'm an editor at
bloomberg brad is the author of amazon
unbound jeff bezos and the invention
of a global empire he is also the senior
executive editor for global technology
for bloomberg news brad thank you for
joining us today hi susie good to see
you
we are going to be taking live questions
from you the audience as
uh brad and i are chatting today go
ahead and drop them into the live chat
below
i'll give you a couple minutes to get
started with that brad why don't we
start by
talking about the excerpt you have
running on bloomberg.com right now from
the book tell us what it was like
to report that piece and i love in in
the piece you talk about
bezos's pr master stroke tell us about
that
um susie the the cover of business week
was jeff winds
and it was because when you look back at
the
totally bizarre events of 2018 and 2019
an aspect of my book which is about the
last 10 years of amazon history and the
rise of
bezos's you know enormous wealth and and
power
uh his ownership of the post and and and
um all the different things like alexa
that amazon did
this is one episode that you know it was
it was completely astonishing
basically the uh emergence of his
personal life and on the tabloid papers
and you look back and you go he won that
right he wins
so many of these battles certainly won
the union battle in bessemer
um uh amazon has prevailed over so many
competitors
and yeah the story that i tell in
chapter 13 of the book in that which is
excerpted in business week
is about how he kind of outmaneuvered
his adversaries the editors of the
national enquirer
you know in part by wrapping himself up
in the mantle of the washington post and
kind of accusing of his enemies of
having political motives
and in part by sort of just not you know
being embarrassed or kind of giving in
to
uh the tabloid newspaper you know which
was trying to get him to sort of stand
down in this battle over
why it had pursued uh you know these
details about his personal life so
it's just like you can't even believe it
the drama one of the world's most
disciplined and smartest
people um getting caught you know
in in this personal relationship that
was somewhat scandalous
and then not being embarrassed about it
and kind of you know blasting the the
editors who came after him
and also you know maybe clouding the
whole situation a little bit with
accusations of
cyber espionage and international
intrigue
i looked into it i didn't think that the
saudis had much to do with it in the end
or trump world
um but you know certainly like you yeah
susie you said yeah pr master stroke you
look back and you go wow
he he somehow emerged from that
unscathed which was the
remarkable thing yeah i thought it was a
really great read i think it's it marks
that the rest of the book is
i'm sure a great read as well but i
actually didn't stay close to that story
so i kind of
left it when he wrote the medium post
and he was talking about you know this
the shadow influence of the saudis maybe
tapping into his phone and i was bought
like hook line and sinker
so then to read your piece and see if
you know spoiler alert for everyone
it was actually his girlfriend's brother
who was apparently the leaker
was fascinating to me you know i i like
many other people probably got that
initial blast
um you know from his pr master stroke as
you said and then kind of moved on and
it and it worked
well susie you made a good decision you
made a good decision to stop
following it um but when you when you
kind of step back
and i tell the whole story in the book
yeah it's it's just really
well you know it's an interesting
episode in itself
and you know fascinating kind of hall of
mirrors of strange characters and you
know the
you know tabloid editors and and
hollywood managers and whatnot
but it also is a sort of way station on
this remarkable
transformation of bezos the richest
person in the world
um that's happened before our eyes and i
start the book in 2010 when
you know he is completely absorbed with
amazon he he
has the idea for alexa almost fully
formed springs from his mind he emails
his executives and says
we should build a 20 computer uh whose
brains are in the cloud that's
completely controlled by your voice
and then he micromanages it you know
invests in it and produces it gets into
the technical details
that's the guy the book starts with and
then at the end
you know he he's building this super
yacht which is another thing that we
write about in in business week
one of the biggest sailing outs in the
world he retires a ceo of amazon
he is known as the defender of a free
press
via the washington post which he has
turned around remarkably
he's in this foot race with elon musk
for space supremacy and kind of
uh falling behind badly there and
amazon's a 1.6 trillion dollar company
so
the book kind of traces this remarkable
transformation it's a story of change
and a story
of amazon coming you know extending its
reach ever
further into our lives which you know
for customers
is is can be great and probably for
regulators and lawmakers and competitors
is something really that needs to be
understood much better
let's stick with that thought of
evolution for a moment you've just
talked about the evolution from the
of the company into what we all know it
is today but i'm curious about the
evolution of bezos as a person
as this company has scaled so grandly
around him what's his leadership style
what's his
approach to managing this business been
is it is it changed the whole time or is
it this laser focused
compartmentalization
that's really allowed them to succeed
it's changed in a number of interesting
ways i think in the early days
um he he really was deeply involved in
all
levels and details of the of the
business um
probably to the consternation of a lot
of his senior executives
and accompanying that was a sort of kind
of brusque management style i actually
have a flashback to let's call it bezos
1.0 in the book
where he uh is presented a document from
a senior
finance executive and he finds a
mathematical error in the appendix
and he says if i can't trust this number
how can i trust anything in this paper
and he rips it up and he throws it down
the the table and he walks out
wow and that's that was bezos 1.0 and
then
again the story of transformation today
he really only closely manages the new
stuff
and he's allowing the bigger divisions
to be operated somewhat autonomously by
his senior leaders
and then what we'll do is every so often
he kind of comes in
and audits the business and pursues a
customer complaint
or some insight that he has had and kind
of makes a nuisance of himself and sends
all the ants scurrying
um and accompanying that i think has
been
i don't want to say a gentler management
style but i think he
knows how to hold himself in check that
his stature
is and and perhaps norms have changed a
little bit where
you probably can't rip up the document
anymore
so it's not a kinder gentler bezos but
the leadership style has changed and
i would say the difference is during the
pandemic he did seem to get much more
involved in
helping to amazon navigate in the early
days but by and large
he's stepping back now andy jassy's
going to be the ceo of the company
but he does have a very keen interest in
for example amazon's healthcare
initiatives he'll meet with that team at
least once or twice
twice a month he is looking for the next
big opportunity for amazon
and that's where he's keeping a very
close eye but he's got a lot of other
things in his world not just the the big
boat that i was talking about
but you know his philanthropy he's he's
now has a fortune of 200 billion dollars
to give away and he's made a big
commitment on climate change and that is
going to require his
attention so his intensity is still
there but it's just spread out amongst
many more things so it's probably not as
consistently you know that that red eye
isn't on everyone
all the time like it used to be the eye
of sauron
that's what i was going for you you
brought it home um i'm gonna grab a
couple questions from the audience in
just a moment but
this is not your first book about amazon
you wrote the everything store another
best seller in 2013.
and i'm curious about the changes in the
company since then numerous fast
uh why was now the time to write the
follow-up the second book
right so the the everything store was
really the first 15 years
of amazon history the the early years of
jeff bezos the founding of the company
the rise during the combust the near
bankruptcy and failure during the uh
sorry the rise during the dot-com boom
the near bankruptcy during the dot-com
bust and then this remarkable
reinvention with prime and the kindle
and figuring out the fulfillment centers
and aws
so that really is the history up to 2010
and i thought you know
oh i've done my work here i'm going to
move on and stop thinking about and
obsessing over
this one person and this one company and
then you know it's like
maybe around 2017 i looked back
and the kindle company had become the
alexa company
the 100 billion dollar market cap was at
that time probably at 800 or 900 billion
and now 1.6 trillion
and the company was taking over our
lives
and raising all sorts of questions about
corporate power
and the use of data and privacy and
monopoly and i thought you know this is
like
an even better story it's a story about
corporate power
and and and and billionaires
and as we've been talking about to see
change and transformation
and so i started it in 2017
and then hq2 uh you know comes around
amazon search for a second headquarters
and that's a story about how comm you
know what communities want from the
companies in their midst and how
what is the corporate responsibility the
license to operate that they need in
terms of
um the relationship with governments and
tax rebates
and that was like an enormous you know
it's hard we've maybe
blocked it out collectively from our
memories but that was an enormous
high-profile saga and then you have the
basil personal saga
and then an anti-trust investigation and
then the pandemic
and so it really was i i kind of joked
that i had written the star wars
with uh the everything store and now
it's the empire strikes back with amazon
unbound
oh well that's my favorite star wars
movie so if the book is as good as that
then you're right
i did youth godfather ii or something
i have a ton of follow-up questions
there but i want to make sure that we
hear from some folks in our audience as
well
we had a question come in earlier from
harsh who asks along these lines of
power he says
is amazon's power over the pentagon and
the washington establishment
going to affect innovation i'm not sure
if he means you know
writ large in the world you could with
with all the power that that company
holds or at the company itself but
take that and run with it i i mean i
think it's a really interesting question
the the
the influence that now amazon has as a
major
infrastructure provider to the pentagon
and and to the u.s government
it has a c it had a cia cloud contract
in 2013.
it's developed its government business
since then
it lost very visibly the jedi contract
to microsoft under the trump
administration but now
has successfully challenged that and
that contract might get
overturned and i think like well you
know one
i think aspect of this question is so
what happens when
the government itself is
uh being counted on to examine
this unique complicated corporate power
in our midst
when itself the government is reliant on
it
uh and then the other dimension of that
is uh how many
politicians you know who now count on
um not just amazon and other tech
companies but their executives for their
you know political action committees and
their re-election campaigns
and so you know we we see before our
eyes this kind of corporate power
tech power becoming very entrenched and
i think it's one of the reasons why
it's going to be you know very difficult
to hold these companies to account
you know in the way that you know
probably they're getting so big
you know that that the situation kind of
demands and then the last piece of the
question which i think is a good one was
well what does that mean for innovation
well you know ultimately it could be bad
because when you have these
star systems of amazon and facebook and
google
and microsoft and apple getting so big
and showing no
signs of you know being checked
you know suddenly it begins harder to
start companies to find clear avenues
for innovation
uh to to to take those companies public
now
i guess the counterpoint is that you
know the startup environment ecosystem
today looks quite healthy and and if if
anything these companies are looked at
as sort of valuable
acquirers so i do think you know there's
that's something to watch the impact of
amazon and its impact
or its influence with the government has
on uh on
innovation largely you mentioned the hq2
project a moment ago and that had me
thinking about you were talking about
the growth of amazon
um as seattle as a microcosm you know
they have the headquarters there
i'm curious your thoughts about how the
community feels about their presence as
they've grown
and if that informed at all the hq2
process
and and how other communities and how
maybe the country of the world writ
large
thinks about them as a company really
conflicted
in fact i was doing seattle town hall
last night a virtual event
and yeah it was it was just really
apparent to me
how you know that the home champion
uh that had almost single-handedly you
know revived
seattle's downtown core was a bit of a
pride for the city
um you know now is seen in some quarters
still as a
as a hometown champion but in many
quarters has the source
or at least an accelerant for a lot of
social ills and you know with amazon now
employs 50 000 people in seattle and
with that has come
you know rapid gentrification um rising
home prices
homelessness um a sense that the quirky
character of the city you know you
remember grunge and
and um you know was really a sort of
blue-collar town
it's kind of being lost and in 2017 when
those battles first started to happen
and and seattle elected some
very progressive uh even socialist
members to their city council who really
started to target
amazon with uh specific taxes aimed at
the company and their executives
there was a sense inside the company
that you know we've done so much for the
city and maybe we're not welcome here
anymore and that really helped to
precipitate the hq2 campaign that and
the fact that they were growing so
quickly
they kind of realized that the city
wasn't going to be able to hold it
anymore
um the the funny thing is how that sort
of storm
of controversy um and resistance to
amazon in seattle
they thought they were kind of kind of
escape from with hq2
and then they ran headlong into the same
dynamic in new york city where they
ultimately had to pull out
and i live in san francisco and in the
bay area the tech lash is alive and well
here so
you know this is like this this complex
and somewhat tense relationship between
cities and the big companies in their
midst is i think a new
sort of fact of life in uh in now
the 2020s and companies sort of have to
adjust
and realize they can't just put their
nose in their business
and not be good corporate citizens they
have to make meaningful contributions to
to their
to their city and in san francisco i
think we see companies like salesforce
really
do that and amazon being sort of
famously
you know closed off and focused on their
customers
it was sort of late late to the
realization
i have a question coming in live from
the audience right now from our
username you can't unhear this it's a
great screen name wants to know do you
think bezos will take a bigger role in
blue origin
as he steps back from amazon are there
other industries
he might pursue next i do think that he
needs to take a bigger role at blue
origin it
on elon you always got the sense was
extremely
present and focused on spacex and jeff
tried to set up
blue origin to run somewhat autonomously
he put in a sort of system of
of invention there um an operating
rhythm
and what happened over the years was you
know as
spacex started to win government
contracts and essentially get paid
you know to go to space and and to
practice and to reach its long-term
vision of going to mars
you know bezos selected blue origin and
he is personally funding it to the tune
of
at least a billion dollars in amazon
stock every year and
and sort of started to accelerate its
ambitions
and and also bid for government
contracts and it just ceded a lot of
dysfunction they changed
leaders i think they've fallen behind
they say they're launching
a new shepard and bringing tourists to
sub-orbital space soon
i don't know susie if you would get on
that spaceship if offered the
opportunity i might be a little
resistant personally
um and you know and i don't know i feel
like they keep delaying new glenn their
orbital rocket
and he needs to get in there if he wants
to sort of
right-size the spaceship so to speak and
catch up he's in danger he had this
dream even before elon did
and spacex is now the preeminent launch
company in the world
and elon has the halo of being the space
pioneer
and so i think bezos if he if he still
wants to turn blue origin into sort of
this meaningful
player in a new frontier then he's going
to need to devote some personal time to
it
and elon likes to get in there and mix
it up with controversial things he's
with the media saying on twitter etc
do you think there's some element of of
that personality
missing in a big um you know creative
interesting
imaginative business like space travel
do you need to have a figurehead
who's out there like musk in a way that
that bezos is not
uh neither you know behind the scenes it
sounds like from what you're saying nor
out in front of the camera
well he it's funny susie that you say
that i think it's a good insight i mean
he has been
visible he's given a lot of his public
appearances recently have been about
space
um he's there at the rocket launches um
he's often the first to to uh you know
appear in front of the cameras after a
new shepherd test launch
but there is an element of showmanship
that elon seems to have around these
space launches
where you see photographs and he's all
he always has expressive and some
element of jubilation in front of the
rocket
he's on twitter often recklessly on
twitter he's gotten into elon's gotten
into all sorts of trouble for
you know various undisciplined tweets
with the sec and lawsuits
and that has bizarrely worked for him
elon was on
snl celebrated on saturday night live
recently
and even his pratfalls around
cryptocurrency and whatnot
end up kind of burnishing his image and
yet jeff is just
too disciplined for that so he's not a
sort of showman
in the way that elon has that elon is
used to his advantage i don't think
it's necessarily an element in
necessarily an element in the success
of those two companies but certainly the
mythology
of elon musk has been burnished by his
ability to kind of whip people into a
frenzy a fandom
and bezos does not do that nearly as
effectively
it's interesting though as we started
the conversation talking about his pr
master stroke he's clearly able to
really manipulate things with
with force when he wants to but there's
definitely a different nuance and tone
to it than the type of interaction we
see
with musk in the media maybe he doesn't
care
maybe he's operating at an altitude
where twitter
for example seems again mixing it up and
you know seems somewhat beneath him
although he has we have seen him sort of
cater his instagram account uh a little
bit more
and we're so we he definitely has a team
that's uh working on
uh on improving his image and getting
him out there a little bit more
yeah i have another question here coming
in live from ashley vance
who wants to know where is bezos in 10
years maybe in outer space like we're
talking about now but what do you think
so ashley vance of course being the
famous author of the
definitive book on on elon musk and um i
remember ashley and i joking at one
point that you know one day
elon would triumphantly travel to mars
and set foot on the red planet
and proclaim himself you know the first
to get there only to discover that bezos
and and his companions have been
sort of living there for years already
um and yet that
prime delivery hubs is sooner than later
exactly a fulfillment center is already
there on march
and yet that joke now seems somewhat
dated because
um you know blue origin has fallen
behind and so in 10 years
it's it's really difficult to say it's
almost impossible to predict i mean 10
years ago we never would have imagined
bezos building a luxury yacht and uh
retiring from amazon um and owning the
washington post and being seen as a
you know the champion or the the savior
of the washington post so
i'm almost hesitant to guess but i do
think in 10 years that maybe he's worked
out some of the
some of the cultural problems that blue
origin
is devoting more of his time there and
then let's let's just be
we'll we'll just suspend our our
journalistic skepticism for a second
and and and say optimistically that
maybe
you know his philanthropy has kicked
into very high gear
and he's applied his like remarkable
intellect to the problem of climate
change
and we can only hope that you know the
bezos earth fund and what he's doing
there has made like a significant
difference
in the rate uh that our club that our
planet is warming and and he has
said that that is one of his goals and
you know from where i said like i wish
him all the best and i hope he gets to
that quickly
because you know we need his time and
energy and brains
spent on the problem of climate change
let's stay on that philanthropy aspect
for a moment since their divorce he and
mackenzie scott have made different
headlines you know mckenzie of course
for
donating so much of the the fortune to
philanthropic
efforts do you think that that's changed
the the narrative he wants to put forth
about his own
approach to philanthropy i don't think
so i i don't i don't know that they're
in the sort of competitive uh
mode in terms of giving giving away
money i don't know it's like
it's hard to it's hard to have any
insight into
into the into the kind of post-marriage
dynamic
it does seem maybe a little frosty from
afar
um the i think the bigger challenge for
for bezos is
you know he wants to he wants to give us
money to to climate organizations
and yet there are organizations
particularly on the on the progressive
left
who are are wary of of his money
and of amazon particularly with its
labor record
and you know he that that's i think one
of the more
important parts of the labor movement
right now this idea of climate justice
and protecting low-income uh communities
you know from the from the impact of
climate change and he's expressed the
sort of willingness to help there
and a lot of these organizations you
know some have accepted uh
some early money from the bezos fund and
then have like posted
remarkable you know statements on their
on their website saying we don't
condone amazon's behavior in in in the
labor markets and so
he's got a hurdle there he's coming he's
coming to climate change
uh into this movement at a time where
there are a lot of serious questions
about
amazon and its impact on communities and
its impact on workers
and so that maybe more than the marital
dynamic is one he's really got to
navigate and
and you know move sensitively through
the trickier of the two arenas
we have another question coming in from
the stream from ozan who wants to know
he says amazon is known for moving
profits
from its not so profitable industries
how long can that last and is playing in
every field
really bases his vision for the company
well i mean i actually think that's a
sort of
maybe a little bit of a misnomer that if
if
the questioner is suggesting that
amazon's um
you know propping up some of its older
businesses with its more profitable
uh divisions you know that maybe was
true at the beginning but you know aws
enormously profitable business you know
is largely financing the creation of
more aws
they're building more data centers and
trying to lower prices and competing
fiercely with microsoft and google
you know amazon retail was depending for
years on
the advertising business and i have a
story in my book
it's a whole chapter in this remarkable
scene where bezos is tugging and tugging
at a document asking questions of his
executives
about the underlying profitability of
the retail business and basically
determining that they're using
advertising as a crutch
but and he wants retail to be profitable
on its own so this idea of
cross-subsidization at least of the
larger businesses i don't think it's
true
um in terms of like amazon taking its
profits
and funding newer things or you know
expanding prime with tv shows and movies
or trying to create the next alexa
i think that that is true it's a reason
why amazon doesn't give a dividend
and i don't believe ever has because
there's this orientation that bezos has
set up
that you know amazon to succeed over the
long term has to keep pulling
more and more rabbits out of its hat in
terms of new products and innovations
and
surprising things for customers and i
don't see that changing
right and and um you know there are
there are lots of reasons for them to do
that one they get a nice fat
r d tax credit uh you know when they
when they invest in research and
development
um but also um you know there's a belief
that
you know when you get comfortable in in
in retail
um or even as a tech company that the
world can pass you by and so they want
to keep
investing in new things we've got a fun
question in the stream here
collected earlier um organ deny says i
wonder if someone on top of a global
company has any hobbies
what can you do to relax as a human
being when the responsibilities are so
huge do you have any insight into that
what what jeff
i'm getting when i hear these youtube
names my i'm always i'm getting a little
nervous like what okay what is possibly
going to come next
um only we filtered out anything that
shouldn't be coming out
yeah um well i mean you know we talked
about
the fact that he's building this super
yacht and and that was never really a
you know a past time that i thought
bezos would indulge in so clearly like
the hobbies and the interests have
evolved
i think space travel and rockets and you
know that
is certainly been a hobby and an
interest of him
of jeff bezos from a very early age he
gave his
valedictorian speech in high school
about about
uh space travel and opening up the the
space frontier and
he's actually been sort of remarkably
consistent in his vision for blue origin
and he kind of returns
to the same concepts that he had in his
high school speech
uh when he is sort of defining what he
thinks the future for humanity is
in space um i'm trying to think of other
pastimes he's building the 10 000 year
clock
uh this remarkable piece of machinery a
clock that's going to gong every 10 000
years
in his in his ranch in texas i didn't
get
actually too far into that in this book
but you know i
believe construction on that is coming
along um
and he's got four kids so and amazon and
the washington post so
i i would imagine that probably not a
lot of time for
any unusual hobbies but if there are any
i do not know about them
rocket ships and super yachts are
certainly hobbies that
everyone has familiarity with but it
makes sense if you're one of the richest
people in the world on any given day
uh brad this has been great thank you
for stopping by to answer some questions
from the audience
and to everyone watching thank you for
coming thank you for
sharing your questions with brad author
of amazon unbound
jeff bezos and the invention of a global
empire also senior executive editor for
global technology for bloomberg news
thank you everyone so much for joining
us today
you